[Música]
la cepal alertó que hay riesgo de una
crisis alimentaria causada por la
pandemia al menos 78 millones de
personas podrían caer en inseguridad
alimentaria una situación agravada
indirectamente por la guerra en ucrania
en estados unidos el gobierno de joe
biden continúa los esfuerzos para que el
congreso apruebe una reforma a la venta
y porte de armas la casa blanca invitó
al actor matthew mcconaughey quien
emitió un sentido mensaje en honor a los
niños y maestras asesinados en su natal
ugalde en texas
continúen brasil la búsqueda del
periodista británico shaun phillips que
desapareció desde el domingo en una
región remota de la amazonía junto con
el indigenista bruno araújo pereira
bienvenidos a esta misión con las
noticias más destacadas del continente
americano soy valentina torres sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos iniciamos con
noticias económicas porque la cepal
advirtió que cerca de 78 millones de
personas de la región latinoamericana
están en riesgo de caer en inseguridad
alimentaria debido a la crisis generada
por la pandemia de kobe 19 y agravada
por la guerra en ucrania alva santana
nos amplía no hace mucho es un fantasma
que se está extendiendo por todo el
mundo el de la inseguridad alimentaria y
ahora ha llegado a américa latina y el
caribe donde cerca de 7 como 8 millones
de personas podrían caer en esta
situación estos sólo tomando en cuenta
inflación y crecimiento
esta vez humo que golpea mucho más el
tema la mujer que golpea los sectores
informales que no tengo recursos para
mejorar en lo social se da cuenta que
faltó
lo que significa que millones de
latinoamericanos podrían no tener acceso
a alimentos suficientes inocuos y
nutritivos para satisfacer sus
necesidades
éticas diarias y llevar una vida sana
según la definición de naciones unidas
un riesgo que ha aumentado debido a un
problema mundial la guerra en ucrania
conflicto que ha disparado la inflación
en casi todo el mundo aunque los
expertos advierten que la zona ya
arrastraba este problema entre otros
motivos por la pandemia de kobe 19
invasión no nací realmente como un
efecto de esta guerra sino que también
que nace como un efecto que nace
precedentemente en américa latina y el
caribe los indicadores de pobreza y
pobreza extrema también están al alza
algo reflejado por ejemplo en el aumento
del precio de los alimentos
estrechamente relacionado con la
inseguridad alimentaria al respecto los
expertos apuntan que las medidas para
revertir esta situación son diferentes
en cada país no obstante todos coinciden
en que deben implantarse cuanto antes
en los ángeles eeuu continuó la cumbre
de las américas con el encuentro de
alcaldes en el que participaron diversos
mandatarios locales de esa nación y de
otras ciudades del continente la reunión
denominada desafíos compartidos
soluciones compartidas giro en torno a
la migración y al cambio climático
y continuamos en territorio
estadounidense
los demócratas aumentan sus esfuerzos
para lograr un mayor control a la venta
de armas automáticas desde la casa
blanca el actor matthew mcconaughey
pidió una normativa más estricta al
tiempo que en washington a través de
monumentos por las víctimas llaman a la
conciencia andrés granadillo nos cuenta
más
como cerrar la herida abierta causada
por las armas en washington gabby
giffords un ex congresista que sufrió
una lesión cerebral tras un intento de
asesinato instaló un monumento temporal
por las 45.000 víctimas de la violencia
de las armas en 2020 tapping and saints
detener la violencia con armas de fuego
requiere valor el valor de hacer lo
correcto el valor de las nuevas ideas
ahora es el momento de unirse de ser
responsables demócratas republicanos
todos nunca dejemos de luchar everyone
we never stop painting nancy pelosi la
presidenta de la cámara de
representantes lamento que no existiera
una legislación
pero es un momento triste y desgarrador
cuando vemos estas hermosas flores que
simbolizan hermosas vidas perdidas por
la violencia armada y que el número
aumentado desde el año pasado debemos
actuar from blazer with my heart la casa
blanca busca la manera de implementar
leyes contra la venta de armas
automáticas y aprovecho que el actor de
hollywood matthew mcconaughey es
originario de oval de texas ciudad donde
hace dos semanas murieron 19 niños en
una escuela primaria tras un tiroteo
para que hiciera un llamado por el
control de las armas
necesitamos controles de antecedentes
necesitamos aumentar la edad mínima para
comprar un rifle ar-15 a 21 años meses
un periodo de espera para esos rifles
sin vivir por los rayos según khan
violence abarca punto hereje una
organización sin ánimo de lucro desde el
3 de junio más de 124 personas murieron
y 325 resultaron heridas en más de 300
tiroteos la labor de bailén que tiene a
los republicanos del senado en contra
parece dar frutos podrían llegar a un
acuerdo para subir la edad de la venta
de armas automáticas de 18 a 21 años
también en eeuu se espera la decisión
final del tribunal supremo sobre el
futuro de la sentencia roe versus la ley
que regula el derecho al aborto a nivel
federal desde los años 70 pero en
algunos estados la interrupción del
embarazo está restringida e incluso
prohibida vamos a conocer el testimonio
de una residente de texas que decidió
auto gestionar su aborto debido a las
restricciones los detalles los tiene le
ayuda el como muchas mujeres esta
ciudadana estadunidense descubrió que
está embarazada tras seis semanas sin
embargo es cuando usted suele detectar
la actividad cardíaca embrionaria y
fetal y en el estado de texas tras la
aprobación de una nueva ley cuando se
detectan latidos el aborto se vuelve
ilegal pero esto no iba a cambiar su
decisión
tengo 29 años soy propietaria de una
vivienda tengo un trabajo estable mi
carrera ha despegado tengo dos títulos y
si me miras sobre el papel podrías decir
que es una situación ideal para una
persona que se encuentra embarazada pero
al final del día estaba embarazada y no
quería estarlo y no necesitaba ninguna
otra razón además de esa para decir que
voy a buscar un aborto
y le costó dos intentos para lograr
abortar por sí misma gracias a varios
amigos que le consiguieron medicamentos
especiales ella describe esta
experiencia como la más dolorosa de su
vida
fue un reto pero fue un reto que pude
afrontar y que pude manejar sé que hay
muchas más personas en el estado de
texas y a medida que nos acercamos la
decisión de raw muchas más van a
enfrentarse a un reto y no van a poder
superarlo y continuar con un embarazo
que nunca quisieron tener
se espera que a finales de junio la
corte suprema- de mayoría conservadora
se pronuncie sobre el futuro del fallo
contra way de 1973 la filtración de un
borrador reveló recientemente la posible
intención del máximo tribunal de derogar
la ley que regula el derecho al aborto a
nivel federal lo que desató protestas en
todo el país si se concretan los temores
de muchas los estados tendrían potestad
de imponer sus propias reglas cuando de
aborto se trata varios estados ya tienen
listas de restricciones al derecho con
algunas normativas incluso más
restrictivas que las de texas
en brasil continúa la búsqueda del
periodista británico don phillips y el
experto en asuntos indígenas bruno
araújo pereira que fueron vistos por
última vez en la región de la amazonía
brasileña cerca de la frontera con perú
ambos realizaban una investigación para
escribir un libro sobre el impacto de la
minería ilegal en la zona
una de las zonas más remotas de la
amazonía brasileña fue la última
localización de don phillips periodista
británico y de un experto en asuntos
indígenas brasileño bruno araujo pereira
que estaban en medio de una
investigación sobre medio ambiente en la
región
más
[Música]
exigimos a los organismos competentes
que intensifican la búsqueda porque
todavía tenemos una pequeña esperanza de
encontrarlos aunque no encuentre con
vida el amor de mi vida hay que
encontrarlos
no encuentro amor de mi entidad mil
[Música]
usted se encontrará
ambos fueron vistos por última vez en el
valle de javarí región fronteriza con
perú que alberga el mayor número de
tribus indígenas no contactadas del
mundo y fuertemente asediada por la
minería ilegal y el tráfico de drogas
durante su viaje phillips y araujo
recibieron amenazas por parte de grupos
mineros ilegales de la zona y según the
gardian periódico con el que phillips
colabora presenciaron un enfrentamiento
entre indígenas y hombres armados por lo
que se teme por su seguridad y sólo para
chávez está lleno de vitalidad es mi
hermano mayor lo admiro lo quiero a lo
que
apenas nos preocupa que hayan sido
secuestrados por alguien que quería
silenciar la luz que estaban arrojando
sobre las actividades ilegales en la
zona de agua poniente el ricochet sí
señor general philippe se está sentado
en salvador de bahía desde donde ha
colaborado con diferentes periódicos
entre ellos the washington post the new
york times y araujo es un antiguo
funcionario del gobierno encargado de
proteger a tribus no contactadas en
brasil
el gobierno desplegado un operativo en
la zona para dar con su paradero pero no
descarta que ya hayan sido ejecutados
así finalizamos esta informativo pero
volvemos en breve con más noticias
[Música]